hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you loo how are
you I am in Warsaw Poland and I actually
have a special guest my only friend here
the only person I really know in Poland
mr. Paul virzi Paul how are you how are
you bill thanks for having me here
excellent maybe I'll do it like this
I'll just sit there and I'll trying to
move this because I don't have the
equipment that I need Paul yeah since we
last spoke yeah well it's been a long
time since you've been on the podcast
but uh this week we've been to Germany
Estonia Latvia Hungary in Poland yeah
and it's been a great time hands down
Budapest
hands down Budapest hands down food
Budapest last night Budapest was
Budapest was they were all great but
Budapest was so good last night I was on
stage and I and I had that thought in my
head like dude I think I'd I'd tape a
special here that was what that felt
like a hot American crowd yeah didn't
matter where you liked it didn't matter
we weren't hungry they were yeah it was
great Latvia was the best heckles Latvia
I enjoyed Lafayette I the one the one
you know there was a couple times in lot
for you you felt alone up there but do
distonia well ten minutes before I go
onstage and granted I'm going obviously
I'm going cold the only thing I got is
Kenny going we have a space you're
really gonna love them Hey club soda can
he shout out to him he brings me up and
ten minutes before I go up the guy goes
yes stand-ups only been here for eight
years it got introduced in 2010 and I
was like that's a little unnerving to
hear before you go out there but like
yeah they were dressed up really nice
the theater was beautiful yeah
and you go into something and it was
just it's like you said ban those Baltic
States it was [ __ ] it does a little bit
something like definitely a very very
[ __ ] smart and logical Estonia was
like the best looking crowd they were
like dressed so nicely I I felt like I
felt like I got a place the theater was
too nice for what we
yeah but Munich was also like Budapest
final you know depict Munich and
Budapest were we're [ __ ] Munich it
was worth 3:30 show and they were a hot
crowd but all of them have been great
but like those were the two cities that
you didn't have to even think that you
were you were over somewhere but like so
anyways I've been on the road with virzi
now for like a week and I'm a moody son
of a [ __ ] so I know I'm driving him
nuts but you know what's funny is dude
your way of talking like I was just
joking like what did you just say like
volume it up volume up
yeah you said volume it up like I was
trying to figure out because the
recording seemed like it you just have
your own way of speaking and I have to
try to figure out what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
I'm like this this is coming too it's
too quiet in a corner you're just going
like well you know just just volume it
up well I like that volume it you mean
turn up the volume oh no no you just uh
no they did that before you came in you
today I mean just think what do you say
wiped it down with Windex they Windex it
down imagine if they went yeah well you
know the thing is to me and my mother I
got this from my mother my mother always
says like turn the lights look we don't
say turn the lights on and off we say
cut the lights
no not cut the lights what is it oh [ __ ]
I forgot I have another thing in my wife
goes I never heard that turn the lights
up no eternal lights oh you don't even
know this yeah language is so crazy you
don't even know what you say yeah I
don't say turn the lights the way that
other people do do they funny [ __ ] today
so we're leaving Budapest oh this is
great and we've been taking these small
propeller planes and [ __ ] cuz you know
that they're short little flights here
and so it's one of those deals you go to
the gate and then you get on a bus and
then you take the bus out to the
propeller plane and then you know I like
about them they don't give a [ __ ] if
your bag doesn't fit they're like I just
shove it under the seats and get on the
seat next year that it's not like this
[ __ ] post 9/11 yeah you know why are
you being hostile get your bag off the
[ __ ] plane the way they are in the
States
so I get on the thing the bus and first
he got on the bus first and I said he
had a weird looking face what's up he
said dude you just missed it this guy
just asked me to sit next to him like
some total like gay [ __ ] like he like
pat the seat next to him like saw Paul
yeah
be pad on the seat or whatever right so
I'm like really I go maybe it's like a
European thing or whatever but I did
think it was weird because the bus was
so big and a result in C it was always
seats yeah so then later first he's
looking at the guide he's laughing at
him going dude look at his little hat
his hat doesn't fit his head and I'm
just looking over it and I knew it
wasn't Jewish I knew it was something
religious it turned I was a Muslim
it was definitely bigger than a yarmulke
yeah it's bigger than Yahoo so it was
like it was the Muslim at right and then
we finally realized I'm looking at the
guy and he looks just like Mersey and
I'm wrong wait a minute this guy's
probably Muslim thought you were Muslim
he's in [ __ ] Budapest and he wanted
to hang with you and then he ends up and
then were funny he was freaking you out
and your seat was like 10 B and Kenny
goes watch he'll probably have 10 a and
then a and then he goes out to you guys
yeah are you Arabic but the one thing so
bill was right but the one thing you
left out in the story is when I did get
on alone when he said you know like I'm
three people that don't know me I'm kind
of like even you said I get a little too
nice with my small talk like also it
snowed here I like the Amish era dude
you talk to that kid with the sneakers
that went out forever yeah yeah so I
could just talk to a stranger my
grandfather's like that right so I look
at this guy I smile and he smiles back
overly like too much and then he goes he
said something I understand
and then he patted the seat next to him
and looked at me like hey I have this
seat waiting for you and that made me
like a little weird because it was all
empty right I'm going oh [ __ ] maybe this
guy so but bill says due he goes he may
think you're Muslim so sure enough like
he said like he said the guy comes next
to me couldn't have been sweeter I go
sorry about the bed no problem no
problem and then he leans over and I'm
just going [ __ ] and [ __ ] the bill is
right let's not let him it's bad that
you were right but he goes are you a
hairy Pig and I go and I go what because
I think he goes Arabic you Arabic and he
like pointed to my face and I don't know
and he goes you look at her pic and I go
[ __ ] bill was right literally
wanted me to sit with him he thought I
was Muslim how [ __ ] and I
okay you thought he was a gay guy with a
little hat that's the funny [ __ ] ever oh
my god dude
all right I want to talk to you because
this is something that is gradually
going into your act which I think yeah
it's gonna make you stand out and it's
gonna be your voice and it is your your
ideas of luxury yeah your ideas of
leisure amenities amenities your big
into amenities like if there's a mint on
your pillow when you come back you feel
like yes that means something it does
and and this is why I love working with
you not only that were friends you got
class remember in back to school you
know about you mr. Mellon you've got
class because I rubbed off from you
buzzy the guy that read it is college
dorm remember he made the college dorm
Enoch that well no but you go you like
your five stuff you know you're a dick I
wouldn't say yeah yeah you're not a [ __ ]
about it but you like you like nice [ __ ]
you know I love I love listen I stayed
in a budget yeah super AIDS
oh yeah in motel sixes yeah but I don't
I don't stay at the the [ __ ]
ritz-carlton penthouse no but I like
working with you too because you just
like you know certain things and I like
that but yes so I love the little things
I love the slippers I loved it I love
the chocolate no I think I loved it I
loved it the joy that you get out of it
it's just so [ __ ] funny i I don't
know what why those little things mean
so much because those slippers dude if
you've got those slippers for Christmas
you'd be like is my wife cheating on me
yeah these things are so [ __ ] cheap
they're all there they never fit your
feet but you know you come in like dude
you see the robe yeah I know oh my god I
don't know why
Bildad chocolates yeah you would think
that I was raised you would think that I
was raised in the streets
I don't know what I don't know what it
is but like you sitting there we were on
the airplane going I do you know what we
should start an airline first of all
like that cost like billions of dollars
and it goes we call it luxury air and I
immediately go I wouldn't fly that you
like one you wouldn't fly two guys it's
just too on the nose it's trying too
hard I feel like I'd go in there and
they'd be like you know like a leg up
faucet that was like gold but it wasn't
real gold but it was gold in color like
look at the luxury imitation right yes
yeah all of that [ __ ] yeah yeah so we
were trying to come up but you would fly
an airline that had 25 all first-class
seats leather school beds all right this
is this is what we were talking about
right when I was something like that
there's a difference between like classy
bright gaudy there's refined and then
there's showing off and there's just
certain people well I don't know if
either one is right when like I look
like a Ferrari right a guy my age could
drive a Ferrari
and not look like an ass hope you keep
yourself in shape and you can tell like
this guy's he's in the he's into like he
knows how to work on cars he worked his
way up I'm not talking about some
[ __ ] jerk-off
you know pinky ring type of thing right
but like a Lamborghini hmm
a Lamborghini is a young man's car
that's feel like you're in your 20s
you're shirtless you got like a cheetah
on like a [ __ ] leash like like I feel
like the Lamborghini is obnoxious where
the the Ferrari is the shin or clay
right like they like I'm saying what
people like the Lamborghini would be
walking around talking about how much
money it had where the [ __ ] the
Ferrari guy would be like chill see
here's the thing my Greek side is the
classier okay my Sicilian kind of goes
in and is like and and we have that
battle but most of those cars are
Italian if that's made by Italians oh no
I know but that's why I see I like the
chain I love the gold chain so part of
me I love it but I mean you got a gold
chain you literally said that the gold
chain completed yes yes you and Yanis
love that you almost cried when I said
that yeah the gold chain just did
something but I can't go pinky ring
that's where I draw the line so I think
that that's the Greek where it's like no
you can't wear my father 100%
full-blooded Italian the whole thing he
just goes he's he's like into the
jewelry he goes would you go second
chain I would go second chain if it
complimented this the right without this
so that that that's the high-water mark
that chain yeah I mean I would go one
more no no no no Bob say but the other
moba would complement it you wouldn't
you wouldn't then not it was maybe even
like a little
thinner than this around it would
complement it that's it okay just an
accent an accent you look good in a
chain no I want to get a chain no I
think I got a thin rope it would look
good on you a thin one yeah but then I
would start looking like something that
I'm not
which I'm not something I've ever wear a
chain with a cross ever I grew up in the
80s of course I did I had the but I
wanted the smooth one around and my
mother got me the one that's like that
which wasn't in styled and the other one
was the total Guido [ __ ] okay the
flat the rope I ever look like what do
you add oh yeah yeah yeah okay so yeah
no I did this there's a certain thing
about if you have a chain there's a
certain level of [ __ ] you're gonna talk
there's a certain level of that you know
there's something you know they you can
go out and get I would wear it something
like that if I was playing a character
in a movie but like I know I'm not a
chain guy now are you a leather jacket
Katja wear the nice leather yeah I like
what not like but I wouldn't get a
motorcycle one I get one that was like
really like top leather leather but it
was like it was I'm wearing it because
nothing less it's cold outside yeah
you're not alive yeah I'm not trying to
wear it to be like oh look at my leather
coat I can't pull it off dude I'm a
[ __ ] pasty northern European guy you
know I didn't grow up in Southie when
Southie was Southie I wasn't like one of
these you know right I mean I I
basically I didn't care about fighting
somebody else until I got to junior high
and everybody else grew and I didn't
grow and then kids really could [ __ ]
fight once I started seeing people
getting that teeth knocked out nose is
broken I was just like I you know yeah I
mean I don't I don't want to go into
this world I'm too [ __ ] slow you know
I have the anger to do this but I'm
gonna lose and you don't read it's dude
you barely touched us we look like we
[ __ ] fell off a motorcycle
we just bruised so easily were you ever
a are you you're not a sneaker guy
you're not you're not were you ever like
I like sneakers when I was when I was a
kid and I do like some old school ones
but I gotta admit that subset of
American culture where you know you're
in your 40s you're in your 50s and
you're still dressing like it's the
first day of school at the
stop we have like the brand like III
receive made me like respect joints I
like them in that type of [ __ ] but it is
hilarious to me that we've worked some
of the greatest theaters in America and
you walk out with the pair of sneakers
on yeah and like you know you chain out
and [ __ ] like that and to you that's
like dressing up well where I'm from
like oh what's his face Nate Corddry I
worked with him on on [ __ ] the heat
and we were joking about Boston we were
shooting there and he said he goes dude
it's like totally acceptable in but in
Massachusetts to show up to a holiday
party wearing like a Tom Brady Jersey
like people be all you got the away one
oh that's cool I like that it's got the
Superbowl patch on it so I came from
more like a sports culture like that but
there is something I think it's also I
think it's because of being in this
business which has so much [ __ ] about
your age you know you gotta you know you
gotta always try to look younger you got
to do all this [ __ ] always [ __ ] women
[ __ ] like that doesn't happen to guys
too
you know what I mean like if you go bald
that doesn't affect the [ __ ] part you
get off for so I as usual my kunti way
rather than giving in to that and
getting the hair plugs and [ __ ]
trying to you know yeah you know do
whatever I steer into my I keep myself
looking good but it's just like I'm
willing to lose whatever I'm gonna lose
to not come out the other side with the
[ __ ] ant leg caterpillar hairs coming
at the top of my head and [ __ ] you
know face yank back and [ __ ] I'll say
what's [ __ ] up dude it's being in this
business long enough you know you're
gonna see it right now at the 40 yeah I
mean what you're gonna see is you're
gonna you're gonna see the first few
people that you start out with go crazy
someone's gonna go legit crazy
someone's gonna quit it's weird when
they quit if 40s a [ __ ] up one for
people with an odd touch because people
start panicking if they don't have
something going on they're going like
this is my last port hole to get out of
this [ __ ] and actually have a legit
career because I have this 20 year gap
now in my [ __ ] resume that I went out
I told jokes and [ __ ] and and then
you'll see the other people that just
double down they got nothing going on
and then they start getting a little
Botox you know shoe polish is going into
the file and they start throwing Hail
Marys yeah no it's not hair of Mel's at
this point but there's definitely the
throwing the hook and lateral halfback
option yeah yeah all of a sudden they
think the writing bags throw in the bath
the fake punt yeah yeah big punch coming
out right this time so it's scaring me
the thing is the thing is when I was
done I say we were talking about but we
would you know the business thing that I
was talking you about how you carry
yourself in this [ __ ] business right
is there's that thing where you gotta
want it but you can't chase it you have
to really believe in what it is that
you're doing and stick to that with this
weird thing we have to be flexible if
what you're doing isn't working but if
you know if you're not hurting anybody
and not being malicious and you really
have this [ __ ] thing that you want to
do you have to stay on that thing and
when people tell you no you don't take
it personal but then you don't keep
chasing them when they say no to you you
keep doing your thing you keep [ __ ]
killing and all of a sudden they start
hearing about you then they come to you
and then it's everything that they said
before it's water under the bridge and
you have to let it go
you can't ever do that a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] said no to me back in 96 cuz
they're not gonna remember it no and
it's not and you're just gonna come off
and look like a [ __ ] that insecure
[ __ ] yeah yeah well you know I Monroe
you said to me like five years ago I had
just moved into the house upstate and I
go I remember I wanted to get to
tonight's show I wanted to get something
and and you go why the [ __ ] you audition
it for they're gonna look they're gonna
hear about you and then they're gonna
want you and I'm literally thought when
I go to the phone I'm like not thinking
you're delusional you've been in the
business longer than me but I'm going
like bills ten years ahead of me like
what's he talking about easy for him to
say right you know he's not angry way
but just like he I'm trying to get
something like he's there you know I'm
trying to get something and then like
sure enough like last year I did this
monster set at Gotham and the Booker of
The Tonight Show was there and he was
just like hey dude I don't yeah just
sent me like whatever and you know we
obviously I want to work on it this year
and time went by I was working on this
special so I it didn't happen the way I
wanted to
yeah but he just goes yes semi so we'll
and it was just weird how we did kind of
say I don't even need a tape well just
let me know send a transcript like tell
me yeah and I was literally like oh my
god that does happen yeah but don't do I
chased it I you know I chased it right
up to about 2001 2002 and that's when I
said [ __ ] this but I did the whole thing
when it was like whatever the look was I
tried to have the look you know the
[ __ ] goatee I got old stand-up Clips
you know everybody had a goatee so I
grew a [ __ ] goatee I had like you
know sweating that was now people will
look at those things and they'll make
comments like they figured it out which
is one of the things that I think like
literally people listening right now you
guys are ruining so much [ __ ] that you
could [ __ ] you know I don't like I
saw there was something on Twitter today
was like check out all these cool clips
of people hanging out in Hollywood and
all these [ __ ] amazing parties and
[ __ ] that no longer happen because
social media ruined it and and it's just
like and I know every go boohoo they
can't [ __ ] hang out who would do
[ __ ] infinity but all that pulls it's
just like dude I when I came in the
business like that's all you wanted to
hear all those stories about so-and-so
going to the Playboy Mansion all these
crazy [ __ ] parties and all of that
type of [ __ ] and the thing was was they
were fun and now everybody's sitting
there acting like every [ __ ] party
there was some sort of like I don't know
what me two thing that happened and
everybody just had their [ __ ] dick out
and [ __ ] and it's just like it's just
this it was a total [ __ ]
overcorrection now and I'm gonna tell
you something right now that people are
gonna run from this [ __ ] the way
remember think the alt scene for a while
they were acting like the alt scene was
gonna bury like comedy clubs and then
that just ended up fizzling out now how
many cause are thriving driving and now
all those dudes ass withering back into
the comedy clubs right and it's just
like all of that [ __ ] like they any sort
of like extreme thing like that it can't
sustain itself it just eventually what
happens is it's not it goes away the
tears yeah well it levels out yeah
because right now like the behavior that
was wrong is going to be reported from
here or not but now they're just going
like that's like that joke that I do my
act it's like now whether somebody did
something or not somebody has to get in
trouble like they have to throw a body
on the fire
every four to six weeks just to keep it
in the news yeah which I have a theory I
think what's gonna happen is I think
with the whole me to thing and
everything I think what's gonna make it
die down and I could be wrong but I
think things are gonna start coming out
about females I did stuff now I don't
know that that that's that's a [ __ ]
pipe dream because [ __ ] has and nothing
happens to him it's just why you teddy
actually you know what the Nick Cannon
see yeah that Nick can to think they're
all going why are you being so petty
Nick it still was the guy's fault where
somebody [ __ ] did that to a guy if
those are all guys and the Cavs looking
out for his friend he's if he just said
hey man if I don't want to do this cuz I
don't get the people that he said and
Tom does all of their tweets that I read
were clearly them joking around so
that's it they're all jokester all job
that the point is it's all joke though
they're like Kevin Hartz did is he was
joking was ten years ago it was in his
stand-up back and these are the
comedian's yeah and they're acting like
they heard him say this at like at a
party with no setup and punch on I don't
want to keep bringing this up because I
don't want to tend to keep mulching that
over because I'm sure he wants to
[ __ ] move on from it but it is like
this no it's just this this [ __ ]
thing that where everybody's go to they
get out of this talk they they give that
[ __ ] guy John Legend's [ __ ] because
when he took up it was he broke music
for that dudes movie and it's like what
he's supposed to be standing in a shower
to be knowing what the [ __ ] he's doing
yeah like you don't know what somebody's
done if you went to their party and
years earlier you don't know yeah III
pump as much as well as I know you I
don't know what you do well I mean I
call you we call each other not to [ __ ]
I know but yeah it's not like you don't
know
wait what point would you ever call me
I'm saying pill you wouldn't believe
this man one time I took my dick out and
I was blocking this door you would never
tell me that but the thing is is I never
did that I'm saying I'm gonna send you
or whatever fight but if you knew
somebody like that then be like how
could you've been friends with this guy
it's like he had [ __ ] tell me that
[ __ ] yeah he has people who are friends
with people at work and it finds out
there like a [ __ ] serial killer how
could you take a picture with this guy
he'd already murdered for two people
it's like well he wasn't bringing that
up when we were [ __ ] hanging around
the water cooler yeah you know to man
like I feel like a lot of these head
coaches we're talking abouts before you
got 53-man roster and you love them and
one of
does something and then they're like
this piece of [ __ ] new and it's like you
know it's taller yeah that becomes that
that becomes that and then all of a
sudden say that this program is corrupt
and everything like everybody knew and
everybody everybody knew it I know dude
I remember I'm not gonna say names but
one comic got in trouble and this guy
tried to suggest that the entire comedy
club all got together and protected this
guy and I almost did a spit take it's
like the second that guy got in trouble
all anybody underneath him was thinking
is great now I can get his spots I mean
they just don't and there's always
people who aren't in the [ __ ]
businesses just like don't understand
how [ __ ] cutthroat yeah this business
business is [ __ ] it so actually it's
nope that's no different than I imagined
if you're in the oil industry you know
if you're on Wall Street just all of it
when you're going for something that in
the end at least back in the day you're
gonna have a yacht dude and there's
gonna be models on it like your fantasy
when you're in your 20s like the [ __ ]
that people are willing to do dude I
remember after I did my second show ever
I in New York City I crushed and I
walked off and I literally was like dude
I'm gonna be in look like I'm gonna be
you start thinking you're like oh my god
like cuz you're like nobody could do you
don't realize that there's other people
out there yeah you know when you first
start doing like this I'm gonna be a
[ __ ] you know business the first thing
everybody thinks is I'm gonna win an
Oscar I'm gonna I'm gonna have a [ __ ]
special and all that type of [ __ ] and
then once what I what I liked about this
business if in the last 10 years is I've
actually figured out where I want to be
in it so any of that [ __ ] I would love
to still happen or whatever but like
it's just like if I could just traveling
where [ __ ] Warsaw right now like I
just looked out there and I'm looking at
this [ __ ] I can't [ __ ] believe I'm
here I can already tell this was gonna
be like Budapest well I remember we were
walking around Budapest yesterday as
like Paul I was just I like this place
man these people are [ __ ] cool and I
got that vibe from the dude who drove us
over here he was funny I had the
opposite vibe in Estonia when I saw the
guy and he was like okay and I was like
this might not go this way you know yeah
and then when I got to Budapest and I
was like oh here and she said my mother
in lon if you thrown her to take this
and and all of a sudden our odds gonna
be great I got the same vibe here how
funny is it that I saw like a Kia Motors
building and a fortnight poster which
made me think of my son I'm gonna be
great here you know but I will tell you
this bill I noticed this I told you we
were on a train from Munich to Frankfurt
and I just started watching people you
know and people are the same like I saw
this 80 year old woman and they gave
little candies out and a thing and she
took whatever her daughter or whoever
did it and I saw her get her purse and
open her purse look my grandmother used
to do with cookies my grandmother was
like I don't know if it was from when
she grew up because she came here my
grandmother came to the United States
ten years old from Sicily didn't speak a
lick of English would like would like go
to a park and learn English that way at
ten years old
oh my god she was she came at ten years
old a rest her soul she died it I think
she died at 80 80 in her mid eighties so
she probably I need a year now I'm
trying to do the math you throw it when
she tried to do the year when she banned
and she died I'll do it for it she
passed I believe in oh nine oh nine
babies so that's like 1929 she probably
came into 20s 29 yeah yes no wait no is
that 29 was that 19 19 Alyssa at 39 49
50 969 yeah it'd be 1919 right so she
got here let's say 1920 New York City
depression 10 years old never spoke a
lick of English and then she did this
thing where like when we would go out
she would go hey if they take those
cookies and I'm like Graham I don't need
she would literally take two cookies
that with it wrap them in napkins I put
her a bit just that Depression era [ __ ]
yeah I saw this German woman do it and
then I saw like the little kids and I
saw little girls from Germany on their
phone like it's all the same [ __ ] yeah
you know I'll talk about a fight with my
wife and the jury or the jurors ah they
get it yeah everybody's the same human
beings that that's what this trip has
shown me is that human beings are really
all the same in a way which is
Madeleine's your bad ones if I said this
will change how you then
view foreign policy and when there is it
when they're sitting there you know
trying to make I still want the wall I
don't want those a husband kid no but
no but I yeah it makes you think like
well you know dunno but this [ __ ] where
they sit there and they you know would
add like your idea of say the Middle
East and stuff like that it just changes
your like cuz there's that grandmother
there there's the virzi there there's
the me there yeah and then what you have
is the lunatics at the top and they just
get everybody all [ __ ] stirred up
beneath them that these [ __ ] people
are gonna come over here and they're
gonna do this they're gonna do that and
all of this [ __ ] so I don't know you
know what's [ __ ] hilarious about that
that whole [ __ ] Trump thing with the
wall is I didn't realize there's they're
already really basically there's a wall
there there's some areas willing to get
an area he's trying to get the area the
South that doesn't have as much which
they're saying is doing stuff but he
doubled down so much on it that that's
why he's not it's like what is the thing
like I don't think either sides gonna
back down
no because the Democrats can't back down
and he's just getting up and walking out
a guy that prideful that tweets late at
night at celebrities that don't matter
calls single comedians names out as the
president itíd states that guy that said
we're getting the wall done and doubled
down and promised his thing he can't
yeah I can't tell if he's like not used
to here and know if it's insecurity like
I'm not a psychologist
but however he is made up is is he's he
isn't gonna back down I love that tweet
the you show shared demands so we'll
just say share what oh yes I saw what
was the word that they used all these
headlines on foot shared demands
shared demands that Pelosi don't die on
top tops to shut down and don't die on
the shared demands it shared a mission
share demands
yeah the pops does a sinner yeah feet
demands it
well shared demands that this politician
doesn't listen to this reality TV star
that is now president like that's where
the [ __ ] Iraq bill do you know how funny
the headliners shared demands well
what's funny is transparent presence is
so [ __ ] long that you forget that
this is the guy from The Apprentice yeah
yeah it's yeah it's bad you know I just
like that now people are finally being
able to kind of question financially
what the [ __ ] we're doing over in Iraq
because that is the big [ __ ] thing
and that is not that is not Lib
conservative that is just black and
white dude where it's just like how the
[ __ ] yeah like to your kids kids kids
I've still be paying that [ __ ] tab
you know and I think that they should
[ __ ] investigate those corporations
that have made zillions of dollars off
of this well I think of the ones that
are prolonging whatever the [ __ ] it is
we're still doing there I don't know I
mean I don't know enough about it but I
I do I do know how to balance a [ __ ]
checkbook and I do see money coming in
versus money going out assets and
liabilities and there isn't there's no
other [ __ ] business where you
wouldn't you wouldn't right now just be
completely [ __ ] that's another funny
[ __ ] thing about him wanting to build
this wall it's like with what money yeah
cuz they be honest well that's gonna
create jobs and blah blah blah yeah but
then you still have to pay for the
[ __ ] wall yeah and he [ __ ] up man
he [ __ ] up dude by saying Mexico was
gonna pay for it and now American
taxpayers are gonna pay for it did it
it's [ __ ] up but talking about money
we didn't because nobody's gonna
remember that and all people do is like
getting people who are for Trump to
admit that this this financially doesn't
make sense but whatever we know the
money or whatever the [ __ ] it is it's
literally trying to get somebody who's
like a die-hard whatever fan to admit
that that [ __ ] call that went your
way was actually a [ __ ] call like I
would say like not this past season the
season before when that stealer clique
clearly caught the ball against the
Patriots clearly caught a [ __ ]
touchdown when they called it back yeah
now the amount of Patriots fans I'll
throw my own friends under the bus well
the amount of them that would have to be
they would go clearly he didn't make a
football boo rule is the rule yeah yeah
they would say that but it's just like
you know I'm on those guys all the way
long line was saying the Tuck rule is
it's a stupid rule I understand that
they wanted to have clarification or
whatever but it's just at the end of the
day it's like - he had it the guys
slapped it out of his [ __ ] hands and
fell on it's a fumble the [ __ ] game
is over the top rule I've never Tom
Brady being like a man it's the [ __ ]
Tuck rule it's just like whatever but
like I'm trying to get people
politically now you see kissing to look
at people like trying to get like most
of my friends are liberals trying to
get them to see things about the
Clintons or the Obamas or whatever they
just think all about they the best I'll
say is they're not as bad as Bush
they're not as bad as trumpet it's just
like they always just steer it into this
[ __ ] argument where it's just like
you know if this guy's really a man of
the people and he's really such a great
guy
whyever his first two speaking
engagements with two of the biggest
[ __ ] banks out there when all of
these people are upside down in their
houses because of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
because at the end of the day they're
getting paid by the same guys they got
their faces in the [ __ ] pig trough
and this is too big for this podcast I
don't know why we're talking about this
maybe I spend money aside well spend
money you can balance a budget I mean
you can balance a checkbook you wanna
know what I'm not good at it
no I'm getting better I'm getting a bell
tolling how you get Paul Tommy because
his special did so well and now he's
selling tickets he goes bill I'm not
gonna lie to you I'm gonna go through
I'm gonna go through a fur coat face I
wouldn't I wouldn't do that I actually
think that that's too much I do think of
fur coats a little ridiculous I do I
don't know however I do you like him you
liked one well that fighter came in when
he goes it's his [ __ ] polar back that
he looks like the Burger King guy the
[ __ ] he's got the Oh what's his name
the higher the Irish guy yeah no Tory
it's Connor yeah kind of McGregor
yeah he came out with like a white one
and he just started walked it but he did
it like no shirt chain underneath like
that guy that guy's not only one of the
best fighters in the world he could you
get talking he's up maybe got five he
could be a great stand-up comedian so
yes yeah I think Conor McGregor he's
[ __ ] talking I bet him top five he's
he's that wrestler level I love that one
one time when he was doing a promo
yo market do [ __ ] nothing
I love that my favorite one was when
when he goes this guy's tried to give
him [ __ ] and he just turns around he
goes dude oh [ __ ] are you who the [ __ ]
is this guy and even the guys started
laugh and be like yeah I know nobody
knows who I am
I was I was trying to get famous off of
you sorry he had all of them laughing
yeah I remember Ronda Rousey was I
thinking who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is
this guy I love it he goes no do nothing
and he gets he gets into it oh yes he's
on there man he's
they were at that level but I will tell
you this dude I nobody was gonna I told
you I heard things from people but when
he was talking that extra [ __ ] somebody
goes doing this is rocky 3 when that guy
beat him like it seemed like he what is
well cuz I feel like right now what he's
trying to do cuz dude those guys are all
pieces of meat yeah so what he's doing
right now is I think he's realized that
so he's trying to get on the other side
where it's just like alright how the
[ __ ] can I get the most amount of money
without getting my brains beaten in so
he took all that money to fight like
Mayweather it's kind of like in the porn
industry where after a while they're
like [ __ ] this I'm starting my own
website again you know if I'm gonna take
all these hits man I'm [ __ ] make it
now the money's coming to me right
probably a [ __ ] up analogy Thank You
holy shots taking all these shots to the
face man I'm gonna [ __ ] what it's done
Milkha yeah exactly that's exactly it
alright I got to read a couple
advertising then we're done hey do you
have any club dates or anything that you
could no I got a ton man I got a ton I'm
gonna be February through July all kinds
of dates I believe my late February date
at helium and Buffalo tickets are on
sale now but I have a bunch of dates
what I love about you what's your
website you don't yeah yeah right now if
you go to the it's all done the website
to new Palmer's e.com vir Zi the shows
page has all dates from now through 19
and more being added yes and I can tell
you that when we were at Gotham oh yeah
what was it a month ago or so yeah I
went I did a show for the Mozilla's I
love those guys and they they were nice
enough after we did the gig in New York
the month before they had the
after-party at the Cake Boss make the
cake they're just the best guys ever
Stephen Chris so I was like I'm gonna
come back I'll do a night so he did a
night and you you were on stage in front
of me and you didn't know that Seinfeld
was coming down no yeah so we were
having him stretch and Paul's thinking
why do they keep having me do more time
bills in the room and I watched you do
like 35 35 minutes and you were riffing
and you were [ __ ] around and I was
just like wow man this guy's like a
legit headliner I'm telling you dude
hours are gonna come easy much easier
for you oh thank you man
then somebody who like is like a joke
writer which is why I love joke writers
because it's like like how hard much
hard it is for them but you're like a
storyteller you [ __ ] with the crowd I
mean I was like I was really like you
came into your own dude so definitely
check Paul out all right Robin Hood
everybody my one and only read here
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
Kryptos all commissioned free I have no
idea what any of that means they strive
to make financial service services work
for everyone not just the wealthy not
intimidating wave for stock market a non
intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence simple and
intuitive clear design with data
presented in an easy to digest way costs
/ no commission fees does that make
sense to you you just said cost no cost
fees no commission fees is that what
that means anyways I lost you looking at
you phone here other brokerage charges
are up to $10 for every trade Olivier
said no no and you kept looking to your
phone but Robin Hood doesn't charge
Commission fees trade stocks and keep
all of your profits easy to understand
charts and market data place a trade in
just four taps on your smart phone can
you tell high no I don't live in this
world at all like you barely even read
this Robin Hood web platform also lets
you view stock collections 100 most
popular sectors like entertainment and
social media and curated categories like
female CEOs and analyze how about good
CEO and analyze ratings to buy / hold /
sell for every stock learn how to invest
as you build your portfolio discover how
about red-headed CEOs you got any those
[ __ ] companies discovery bald
redheaded male CEOs discover new stocks
and trade favorite companies with
personalized news feeds custom
notifications for price movements so you
never missed the right moment to invest
Robin Hood is giving listeners a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to hell
you build your portfolio sign up at Bill
burr dot Robin Hood calm that's Bill
Bird Robin Hood calm if you're into that
[ __ ] check it out all right that's the
podcast enjoy the music here and
there'll be a half-hour bonus material
from old school throwback Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts all right Paul oh and
stream that stream is special still
streaming I'll say this
Comedy Central broke their online
records please check it out subscribe to
the Comedy Central app and you could get
the special we're going to be putting
out more clips
it's common sense calm but it's also you
could get it right from my website at
Palmers EECOM but if you go to comedy
central comedy and you can see the
special there and check out poverty calm
for the new dates beautiful all right
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and
Monday might be a little bit late
because our unless we record when were
in Vienna but I'll be coming back
I think flying back Monday which might
be your Sunday there's been so far ahead
I don't know all right I'll see you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 10th 2011 how are you why
is that song in my head
Lionel Richie Lionel Richie there's a
good-looking fella huh that was one
weird-looking son of a [ __ ] wasn't it
you know with his his jheri curl
he had a jheri curl a mullet and an afro
all at the same time three of two out of
three of the worst [ __ ] haircuts ever
I think the Afro was cool if you were in
the ABA other than that it was probably
just another reason for racists to not
get along you know you sitting there
you're trying to be open-minded you're
at a [ __ ] sporting event or maybe at
a movie theater and some guy comes
walking in with a big dr. J afro you
know and doesn't have the decency to put
that Frederick Douglas part on the side
so maybe you could look down his part
and see a little bit of Jaws part 2 or
whatever the [ __ ] was coming out when
people had hair like that and what it
creates animosity see that's what it is
everybody thinks it's that slavery stuff
they think it's the Holocaust that's not
what it is it's the haircuts of people
that's why people don't get along you
know you look at other people's haircuts
ideo well what kind of people will get
haircuts like that you know and then
there's some little psycho in the corner
with greasy hair and a weird mustache
and the [ __ ] starts that's how it goes
down people you might be sitting there
right now going cheap bill that was
really [ __ ] ignorant don't you watch
The History Channel as a matter of fact
I do I do watch The History Channel
thank you very much for not asking me
and allowing me to create your question
in my head I do watch The History
Channel and there's there's no history
left on that channel all they show is
pawnshop on that gee I don't know what
the [ __ ] is on that you know it's just
become like every other channel I was
reading something today where they were
doing a mini-series on the Kennedys I
didn't see the bridge and am I really
gonna do a hacky Ted Kennedy I think I'm
gonna and
we went down to the bottom a little goat
and I took a deep breath I finger [ __ ]
her a couple more times left her in the
car and swam to the surface actually the
size of my head made me so buoyant I
just sort of floated unconsciously your
honor yes sir they had a miniseries
about the the Kennedys and they canceled
it they canceled it yet for some reason
evidently if you have a bunch of [ __ ] in
a storage shed they want to go down and
film it was that a little social
commentary is that what I did two
minutes and 49 seconds into the podcast
did I really just do some sort of what
is the state of the History Channel
commentary I think I did okay well I
have an announcement to make
and it's with heavy heart that I have to
tell you that my three-week vacation is
over you know yeah it's back to the
goddamn grind and I know a lot of you
right now going three weeks do it I get
[ __ ] two weeks for the year well you
know what that's your fault
all right you picked that career it's a
free goddamn country go write some
[ __ ] jokes you can't maybe then you
you could take a three week vacation and
buy vacation what I meant is I I didn't
have to get on a plane I didn't have to
go to any airports for three weeks
was awesome I was actually hanging out
with some people the other day and they
weren't comedians but they traveled a
lot and we just sat around talking about
different airports and it blew my mind
how much I knew about all these airports
and places where you could get something
decent to eat and buy decent of course I
mean by airport standards you know I
know whenever I land in Dallas I'm gonna
come down that [ __ ] escalator
forefront of my connecting flight and
there's that awful Mexican restaurant
that's right there and every time I go
in there because I'm hungry and I hope
against hope that they're gonna have the
real cheese and not that Cheez Whiz you
know that cheese come that they put on
the burritos and every time I order a
[ __ ] burrito I said hey listen this
burrito does it have the real cheese or
does it have that
nuclear waste cheese with stuff and the
waitress never knows you know because
who's kidding oh if you're a waitress at
an airport you don't give a [ __ ] you
know I don't know let me go in and ask
the chef then they go why didn't they
come back so what's the verdict there uh
what's a good Texas [ __ ] name Tacey
you what's what's the verdict there
sweetheart is it do you have the real
cheese
we certainly doubt nodding the head you
know mine [ __ ] you like you got to
get an you know nodding up north means
yes down south it could mean yes or [ __ ]
no why we most certainly do not
we absolutely don't uh with your big
[ __ ] those big [ __ ] tax our can of
those Oklahoma that [ __ ] huge white
girl face that that Hugh Hefner loves he
loves those girls those big Panhandle
faces huge [ __ ] heads Texas Oklahoma
Arkansas white girls got the biggest
roundest [ __ ] heads I've ever seen in
my life
jesus [ __ ] christ they played
football you couldn't get him a helmet
you'd have to get up to custom-make
helmets for the beautiful bodies you
know big vanilla titties huh
that's right big vanilla titty so yeah
big vanilla titties they got you know
the stars at night or big and bright
just like my big [ __ ] head you know
if I just slap the [ __ ] out of any woman
I don't I think I can't yeah I think
it'd be with some chick from [ __ ] Tex
rki Oklahoma you know just get a big 12
ounce club write boxing glove
big fruit card of a [ __ ] head all
right speaking of which i will be in
addison texas now that I've trashed your
women your women I'm gonna be there the
last weekend in in January so if you get
a chance you know you know you put on
your best pair of boots is that what you
guys do out there in Dallas why am i
[ __ ] on this is the second week in a
row I've [ __ ] on people in the in the
Greater Dallas area and I still have the
audacity to think that I'm gonna sell
tickets down there Jesus Christ is this
the Chinese year of arrogance because
that's what I'm feeling
anyways so two more weeks of no boozing
and I've made my 100 days 100 days I
think about you a hundred ways what song
was that was that a Jane's Addiction
song or was that when they were porno
for Pyro's piracy huh
was that Tahitian moon is that what I
was just singing there who was it Bali
in my eyes am I the is it anybody else
in the podcast I'm a mime I like the
only person who ever bought that CD mmm
the second porno for Pyro's I like Bali
that song Bali I don't like the weird
high-pitched singing that Perry Farrell
does in the beginning of it but I really
like the sound of the guitar just in
case you were wondering you were just
sitting there going you know I wonder
what Bill thinks about that obscure
track what is it the [ __ ] last song
second side [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] all
right what the hell am I talking about
okay let's let's talk about something in
sports that really
[ __ ] bothered me this weekend I was
watching the Bruins Canadiens game ok a
horrific loss for the Bruins we were up
tuning up and then we lit up two [ __ ]
goals and then right in the end and lost
in overtime but this is what pisses me
off about the [ __ ] Canadiens is the
Canadiens
are sort of like they're like Matt BAM
Matthew McConaughey's character and
Dazed and Confused remember that guy the
26 year old guy who's still hanging out
at high school wearing his [ __ ]
letterman jacket asking where the
parties are that's what they're like
they are a still the most successful NHL
franchise in the history of hockey but
they have not dominated the league since
pre Gretzky will talk in 1979 we're
talking Jimmy Carter in office alright
we're talking about the the AMC Pacer
being a viable option for a car of the
future I know I just realized because I
Drive a Prius that I bet if me live
might was my age in 1979 I would have
bought it I would have bought a pacer
I really just learned that about myself
it makes me feel bad so anyways just to
give you a little bit history between
the Bruins and the Canadians the
Canadians kicked the [ __ ] out of the
Bruins for a good 50 [ __ ] years all
right
dominated the league we met him in the
final seven times and we never beat him
and every time we went up to the to the
Montreal Forum they always beat us and
it was like this hex we just couldn't
beat it right and this is the weirdest
jinx in sports because in 1987-88 we
finally went up to the Montreal Forum we
finally had a better [ __ ] team well a
couple of times we had a better team but
we would still lose but we finally had a
better team and we [ __ ] beat them
right it's over the [ __ ] hex is over
oh thank god right
just for better measure two years later
we beat him again in the [ __ ]
playoffs you know and then over the next
20 years we pretty much went tit for tat
in the playoffs playoffs and two years
ago we beat
Montreal every [ __ ] game in the
regular season and then we swept them in
the playoffs the final two games in
their own building okay but for some
[ __ ] reason they still always talk
about this [ __ ] hex like it's still
going on
I for the life of me can somebody hockey
fan please [ __ ] explain it and don't
even say it's because the Bruins haven't
won a cup because we did during that 50
year [ __ ] drought we won in 70 and we
won in 72 that would be like if the Red
Sox won it in 70 and 72 when you're
still talking about the curse of the
babe I don't know what this [ __ ]
curse is is it because we haven't beaten
them in the finals ever
we can't they realigned the divisions
we've played them in the playoffs we've
beaten since 87 we're pretty much 50/50
against them I don't [ __ ] understand
I understand it when Dan Shaughnessy
says something because Dan Shaughnessy
like if an old 80 like an 80 year old
woman became a sports writer she would
be Dan Shaughnessy because Dan
Shaughnessy never talks about the game
Dan Shaughnessy loves ghosts and goblins
and [ __ ] urban myths he's everything
about the [ __ ] game he will talk
about all of it like and he doesn't know
[ __ ] about hockey all right as he asked
actually called for the end of the
Winter Classic this week he said you
know it's time to retire the Winter
Classic this is this is this is what a
[ __ ] this guy's he talks about how the
first [ __ ] three years were awesome
and now he stood next to Bobby Orr
arguably the greatest player of all time
you know if not top two if not top three
if you're a [ __ ]
you know the [ __ ] arguing greatest
play of all time stands next to Dan
Shaughnessy when the the Winter Classic
was at Fenway Park and he says to
Shaughnessy this is what real hockey is
this is what it is this is it this is
this is it and it's it's its most pure
form this is how we all learned how to
play all right and then this year just
because you know one year that you
have bad weather it was kind of raining
out the ice wasn't good
Shaughnessy says that they should cancel
it he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's like Dan those first three years
that's pond hockey in the middle of the
winter what you saw in Pittsburgh is
pond hockey at the beginning and the end
of the pond hockey season all right if
you ever [ __ ] plating in your life you
dumbass the second I saw that Pittsburgh
Washington game and I saw the ice
surface with those puddles I immediately
was taken back to my youth during you
know just the beginning when it was just
cold enough to play hockey or you were
coming into spring and what would you do
you take big rocks should throw them up
in the [ __ ] air see if they would go
through the ice and then you'd send the
fattest [ __ ] you've out of all your
friends to walk out on the ice and if he
didn't drown game on
you'd go out there and you would skate
you know and if you started losing you
try to trip one of your friends into the
big puddle so whatever so anyway so I
want to know seriously okay now Montreal
Canadiens I'm not disrespecting you guys
you guys you know other than the New
York Yankees you're the most success you
have the most championships alright and
if I had to rate franchises I would say
Yankees Lakers Canadiens and then
Celtics I know a lot of Boston fans
aren't gonna like that but this is this
is why
all right Yankees cuz they got the most
and they've won in every era then I
would go I would say I would go Lakers
just because they've won 10
championships in the last 30 years that
no Canadiens haven't Yankees haven't I
mean that's [ __ ] unheard of in the
modern era with free agency that that's
that's [ __ ] and saying well so I guess
I would put that maybe I would say ok
well I don't know where to put the
Lakers how about that I'll put the
Lakers is the best franchise in the last
[ __ ] 30 years without a doubt
um and now I can't remember what the
[ __ ] I said about the rest of the [ __ ]
all right
but I don't understand like what exactly
has to happen how many [ __ ] times do
the Bruins have to beat the Canadiens
and the [ __ ] playoffs I don't get it
and we've once we won two Stanley Cups
during I just I don't get it
I I absolutely die I do not [ __ ]
understand why every time I watch the
Canadiens Bruins they have to bring up
something that ended that [ __ ] ended
Jesus Christ almost a quarter of a
century ago the Canadiens have not
dominated the Bruins for any significant
amount of time since 86 pre 8 1986 I
don't know if I got the Canadian feed I
have no idea what but that is the most
overrated [ __ ] thing I've ever heard
and any time the Canadiens win like they
did came back and won their they'll be
like you see you see and but they'll
they'll ignore the fact that we swept
them for a whole year and in the
playoffs the final two games in their
own [ __ ] building you know how come
the Red Sox how come that thing ended I
don't I don't get it whether that
wouldn't shouldn't that that thing have
continued the whole [ __ ] thing
doesn't make sense it's just this
classic thing is a Boston sports fan
which I'm so [ __ ] sick of is I can't
stand first of all I don't believe in
curses that ho Dan Shaughnessy old
[ __ ] lady thing where it's such a
[ __ ] way of looking things where you
literally take your hand off the wheel
you have no control of your destiny
because there's a goddamn gremlin under
your bed it's like isn't it really that
aside in fact that Montreal was a
tremendous [ __ ] franchise back in the
day all right as tremendous as they were
the Bruins were horrific wasn't it that
you know Harry Sinden didn't embrace
free agency and he resented
[ __ ] resented the fact that players
were now in control and he absolutely
categorically [ __ ] refused to pay
anybody top dollar whether they were
worth it or not wasn't that wasn't that
more likely than that there was some
sort of [ __ ] ghost floating around a
[ __ ] hockey arena I don't know so
whatever so for the 900th [ __ ] year
in a row I got to watch a Bruins
Canadiens game and despite the fact that
the Montreal Canadiens are not a factor
in the NHL anymore they're in first
place now but you know what I mean that
they're not an elite franchise anymore
they're just not and they haven't been
ok they haven't won a [ __ ] Cup since
93 it's over it's over ok it's [ __ ]
over I mean I don't know I mean it's a
Celtics fan I I admit that it did it's
it's over it it died when Len Bias died
when Len Bias died it was [ __ ] over
and it hasn't come back just because we
won one since then it hasn't come it's
[ __ ] over you know speaking of which
I've actually started to watch a lot of
hoop and I got to tell you something
when the [ __ ] Boston Celtics I've
never seen so many goddamn ace bandages
and knee pads in my entire [ __ ] life
I think they have the oldest legs in the
enha in the NBA
every one of them is taped from their
ankles up to their hips I don't think
that I I really just don't see them
winning it this year I don't I think
that uh I think Miami Heat's gonna do it
I actually think they're gonna do it
they're they're they're they're much
younger the [ __ ] everybody's dressed
like Marcus Haynes on the goddamn
Celtics that is an old reference for you
huh Marcus Haines look it up people he
was uh the the magical [ __ ] the guy
in the Globetrotters right and each
slide around on the floor you know what
black people [ __ ] about [ __ ]
Hollywood in that type of [ __ ] don't we
do to white people you know for the the
stereotypes and the awful roles which
they've been given for decades in
Hollywood you know to white people get
any sort of credit for
being on the Washington Generals and
just being absolute Stooges you know
what I mean just going out there paid to
lose paid to fall for the same [ __ ]
trick every goddamn night just looking
like absolute [ __ ] buffoons do we get
any sort of a credit can can Spike Lee
make a tragic film about white people
who had to play in The Washington
Generals anybody can anybody back when
me up back me on that one
back me up people what's the deal um how
far to this [ __ ] podcast am i 20
goddamn minutes alright so what is there
to talk about you guys uh what do you
guys want to talk about I sound like a
headliner right now who has run out of
jokes he's done an hour's worth of
material in 20 minutes so now he's just
gonna try to [ __ ] play with the crowd
which I can't do because you're not here
so why don't we read this this email
under the provocative name corporate
[ __ ]
dear bill recently I had to return some
items at the mall it was the day after
Christmas and I was with a girl I was
dating a with the girl that I was dating
she wanted to return some shoes so we
went to the journey store where the
shoes were bought when she got to the
counter to return the shoes the girl
behind the counter asked her for her
name address email and phone number oh
my god the amount of [ __ ] people who
actually give out that information
my girlfriend just gave the information
over as soon as the girl asked for it we
were leaving the store I remarked that I
thought it was [ __ ] that she had to
give away personal information to return
a pair of shoes she said it was not a
big deal
but I didn't like it all right why the
[ __ ] would you give somebody all in
information and just in case you're new
to my podcast just say you can say no
can I you know I go out to buy [ __ ] all
time could I have your phone number no I
don't even say I don't even try to make
it nice I just say no and then they go
oh okay you know why do you feel like
you got to give them their information
you
to buy something I'm sorry I can't I
can't sell you this unless I get your
information well then go [ __ ] yourself
I'll buy it somewhere else I don't even
need it anyways so anyways he goes next
we go to American Eagle you guys hit all
the hot spot huh then we went to thin
abun next we went to American Eagle
where I had to return a shirt that was a
gift there was a long line for returns
why'd you return the shirt hon did it
not fit or was it ugly as health or was
it both as I was waiting in line one of
the employees comes up to me with a
clipboard with a little form to fill up
now is anybody else kind of getting the
prison camp vibe here you know you're
standing in line to get processed and
there's a guy coming up onto Vata is
your name please your phone number I
stopped the employee I stopped the
employee and asked her why she needed
this information and she says that it
was to verify my purchase how [ __ ]
dumb are people you gonna verify my
purchase well here's the sales slips
there sweetheart
this verifies it that's it I don't know
what to tell you why don't you and your
clipboard why don't you hold that
clipboard between your little [ __ ]
beef curtains and take a [ __ ] walk
down the street how about that I
sweetheart there's no reason to use that
type of language go [ __ ] yourself oh how
about I [ __ ] grab that ponytail and
just no let's let's let's keep it clean
this week shall we people anyway she he
goes before I could protest further she
said that I could just put my name on it
Oh on the clipboard when she walked away
I pulled out the gift receipt but said
to my girlfriend oh here it is yeah this
is what verifies my purchase exactly the
clipboard employee wasn't as far as way
as I thought she was and heard me say
did I read that wrong yeah heard me say
it's heard me say this and she began to
explain further why I needed to give
over the information this is the part of
the email I hate he goes I apologized
and told her I realized it wasn't her
and that it was just her company's
policy that she was enforcing she walked
away a
I felt bad so the next time I saw her I
apologized and said I realized that she
was just doing a job but she ignored me
she was probably pissed because it was
the day after Christmas and I was
causing her grief but you could at least
accept my apology you [ __ ] I love how
you go from being totally liberal in
seeing somebody's [ __ ] side of it to
being yeah man up you [ __ ] anyway I got
up to the counter and there wasn't any
further problems the guy at the register
just took my name and didn't ask me for
anything I felt as though I had a small
victory against the big corporations
then this week I had to go back to the
store to return a hack my girlfriend gun
did you guys not make Christmas lists or
all your relatives blind this seems to
be a lot of returning of gifts this is
hilarious you're returning a hat that
your girlfriend got you dude how
horrific was that hat can you please
send me a picture of it before I if you
took one before you returned it picture
one of those a plaid Charlie Chaplin hat
I had the receipt but again the girl at
the register asked me for my address and
phone number I said I didn't want to
give that information to her immediately
panic sets in in her face and she says
that I have to I said that I didn't have
to the day after Christmas and I wasn't
going to now good for you she calls over
a co-worker and they both get defensive
and hold to the idea that I have to give
over my information in order to return a
stupid hat even though I had my receipt
I asked why and they let me slide why
did they let me slide on this before and
they maintain that I had I had to give
them my name address and phone number so
what did I do in the face of corporate
opposition I caved and I gave it to him
you [ __ ] dude the second you saw the
panic on their face you knew that they
were gonna lose all right he goes I just
don't get it bill why is a receipt not
enough nowadays it is enough they say
they need our personal information to
verify purchase then not dude they're
not all right all of that [ __ ] all those
little save you know you want to get one
our discount store they're creating a
I'll on you they figure out what you
want to buy what they can market towards
you and then they take that information
and they sell it to other [ __ ]
companies even though they say they're
not going to they sell your information
your information gets up on the internet
and that's why there's all these creepy
web sites out there right now that have
all this [ __ ] information about you
about you know how many siblings you
have your brothers and sisters names
they all use that information to [ __ ]
ditz I'm telling you this don't give
them your information you don't have to
give him your information and people out
there who just have this [ __ ]
attitude towards these corporations just
sitting there going like wait you know
what do they get you mean as long as
you're not doing anything wrong I mean
what do I care if they know where I live
it's [ __ ] morons
I don't even I've explained this [ __ ]
till I'm blue in the face and then I
always get these emails from these
people they just I don't need I don't
know I can't even I said something the
other day you know I've said that listen
I was sitting there I was listening to a
sports radio you know cuz I'm a deep
thinker
right and this new guy got on sports
radio out here in Los Angeles
and you know he does what most people do
when they have nothing to say which is
they they just start they just go
over-the-top arrogant you know what I
mean like he was talking about how he
wanted to get some some sort of sports
coach or personality on the show but he
doubted he could get him as a guest
because the guest hated him and he goes
you know cuz I disagreed with them on
something he yeah he was talking to a
coach and he was actually disagreeing
with with the [ __ ] coach he's
disagreeing with the guy and he goes you
know what the problem is you know he
goes like I'm just like such a good
debater I actually end up like
convincing myself of my own opinion he
actually said that over the airwaves and
I just sort of muttered to myself that
the confidence of morons is staggering
you know what I mean morons
think they know everything that's that's
what makes them [ __ ] morons
and like the emails I get with people
who don't question this [ __ ] which is I
don't know if like last week when I when
I went out for my little [ __ ] rant
there just some of the [ __ ] emails I
get it's like people are sending me [ __ ]
that kind of is backing up what I'm
saying and then telling me that it sound
like I have tinfoil on my [ __ ] head
which obviously I am out of my [ __ ]
mind on some level but I'm not out of my
mind when I don't trust corporations and
I don't trust them when they say we're
not gonna do anything with this
information the other day I was in CVS
and I go to buy something and the lady
asked me did I have a save card and I
said no she said do you want one and I
said no and she goes well that's okay
I'll just and she swiped the [ __ ]
thing anyways and I was like lady what
did I just say to you now see if I use
my credit card
they'd have my name and then to match up
to that [ __ ] number and what the hell
I just bought and just a little bit more
information about me and my question to
all you people who have these this faith
in these corporations why does that
person do that why are they so hell-bent
on trying to make that corporation less
money in that moment they give me this
card you know like everybody has those
cards so you're not saving any [ __ ]
money it's just it's a big [ __ ] shell
game to make it seem uh look you're
saving money what they're really doing
then I look at this hand over here as
you're giving them all your personal
[ __ ] information that they can then
use to very least sell to other
corporations to increase junk mail and
also to limit your [ __ ] level of
privacy the fact that they can put all
that [ __ ] up in the goddamn internet
people have been sending me these random
websites where they have like your name
and your address where you [ __ ] live
and all this type of [ __ ] it's like how
do you think that they get all that
information do you think there's
somebody sitting there with a phone book
and just typing all of this [ __ ] in I
don't know I'll [ __ ]
if some list of lists what kills me if
some [ __ ] random creepy guy you know
you're standing there waiting for the
subway came up to you asks you what's
your name your phone number and your
address was would you give it to him now
but for some reason you're inside of a
[ __ ] store and there's socks and
sweaters and somebody has a nametag now
all of a sudden you you give them total
[ __ ] and trust you're out of your mind
so sir don't cave in all right all you
just just say that's unacceptable
that's unacceptable I want to speak to
the manager what they're doing it's not
legal yet it's not legal yet but I can
guarantee you there's somebody lobbying
for it that in Washington there's some
sort of [ __ ] high-powered lobbying
group I swear to God is probably
lobbying that from here on out we need
to have a law that if you're gonna
return a hat you have to give us your
name your address in your social
security number just so there's not
another 9/11 could guaran-fucking-tee it
so yeah you don't have to that's
actually one of the highlights of my day
what I do now is when they say do you
have our little savvy safe card and I
say no I don't would you like one no I
don't I Ben say and please don't swipe
another one you know and then I try to
pay with cash I love cash cash is [ __ ]
anonymous all you guys out there who was
sitting there watching these commercials
where they make it look like credit
cards are so [ __ ] easy
you're idiots if you're buying into
exactly what they want you to buy into
which is a cashless society so they can
keep track of where you are at all
[ __ ] times and every last [ __ ] dime
that you make so they can get their
greedy little [ __ ] hands on it you're
out of your mind
and you're giving up an unbelievable
amount of [ __ ] privacy by creating a
paper trail everywhere you go everywhere
you go what you're doing where you're at
you know and this
of morons who were gonna sit there and
go wolf you ain't doing anything wrong I
mean I guess maybe maybe I'm a paranoid
psycho you look at all these [ __ ]
idiots who do reality TVs and they let
cameras come into their house and they
don't seem to care about it maybe maybe
the average jackass doesn't give a [ __ ]
but sir for the love of God you know in
the end he says I'm not crying
conspiracy it's very plain to see what
they're doing it's not malicious or evil
yes it is it is malicious and it is evil
and it is a conspiracy they're
conspiring to get everybody's
information find out what they buy and
they're lying to you saying that they're
not going to share the information
it's everything that you're saying it's
not it is all right and that's it that's
two weeks in a row I'm on the soapbox
see people don't you like it better when
I talk about sports anyways let's talk
about football this week you're gonna
hear me say something this week that
I've never said before ever on a podcast
I feel bad for Peyton Manning Peyton
Manning got [ __ ] this week by his own
goddamn coaching staff he played a great
goddamn game when they needed a scorer
he drove him right down the [ __ ]
field if that bum caught that ball they
were right in there and even still and
by the way an invented Terry it's a
shame that Jets won the goddamn game
because that guy is the most money
kicker of all time I was actually joking
with my buddy when I was watching the
game I was saying that the most [ __ ]
ever gotten by a professional kicker has
to be out of Adam Vinatieri it's got to
be it's got to be and I actually learned
that there's no kicker in the NFL Hall
of Fame and there's no [ __ ] way it's
just a shame not cuz I even that I hate
the judges that's a shame that the Jets
won that [ __ ] game because it people
are gonna forget that he actually hit
that [ __ ] 50-yard oh man right down
the [ __ ] middle right down the middle
but uh I don't I was right there with
Peyton Manning when he was had his hands
out when they called them when the
[ __ ] cults called timeout with 29
seconds to go can somebody explain why
the [ __ ] they did that and don't even
say well a third point to realize the
Jets were gonna kick a field goal and
they wanted to make sure that what
they'd have 17 seconds to get down the
[ __ ] field there wasn't gonna be
enough time there wasn't gonna be enough
time you had a second-year quarterback
who who [ __ ] had that deer in the
headlights look
he was overthrowing all his [ __ ]
receivers you can you take a timeout you
give him a chance to gather himself for
their coaches to give him the next three
plays so we can [ __ ] relax and what
comes to comes right out he hits a
[ __ ] 18 yard pass and that's the end
of the game and when Peyton was sitting
there with his hands out like what the
[ __ ] are we calling timeout for it was
the one time I have I actually felt bad
for that guy I just sat there and I was
going I think they're in the process of
losing this [ __ ] game not it just
giving the game away was [ __ ] brutal
absolutely brutal so there you go Peyton
Manning did not lose that game he
[ __ ] stepped it up he played a hell
of a goddamn game and I actually feel
bad for the guy that he that he lost and
if I'm gonna be honest now that I think
about it about five six years ago you
know he drove his team down the field
and their idiot kicker would talk [ __ ]
about Payton choking in the playoffs he
went on and he missed the [ __ ] field
ghost so there's two years two losses I
won't
I won't blame Peyton Manning for all
right there you go see that look at meek
trying to be a little more forgiving in
in this year and and I realized this
week too that I've been feeding into
exactly what Rex Ryan wants which is
people just talking about him you know
what are the odds he think he think he's
going to say something outrageous this
week it's really like watching Madonna's
career you
well you have a woman who has a mediocre
voice and has made mediocre music for
the last 30 [ __ ] years
yet somehow yeah whenever she wants to
be as in the news and you know why
because she knows when to take her clam
up
alright she knows when to go on
Letterman and say [ __ ] 38 times during
an interview you know when you really
think about Madonna what does it have to
do look how good shape she's in did you
see when she did the book and she
[ __ ] spread her legs you know did you
see when she said [ __ ] on Letterman did
you see when she did the video and
[ __ ] Jesus was black and then she
kissed him of course that's what you
talk about what are you gonna talk about
borderland feel like I'm going to lose
my mind really thirty year career off of
that horseshit what's-his-face is doing
the same thing he's doing the exact same
[ __ ] thing dropped a bunch of f-bombs
during hard knocks that was his
Letterman episode alright he put a wig
on that was him showing his clam and
then then he made a controversial video
other than that he lost the division
backed into the [ __ ] playoffs
playoffs yeah I don't know you know you
know I realized this week I didn't even
know who what the name of the coach was
for the Atlanta Falcons I've given this
guy no hike whatsoever Mike Smith I had
actually actually had to look it up this
is a guy who went 13 and 3 who actually
has has actually has a franchise
quarterback in Matt Ryan he actually has
a franchise quarterback you know but
it's not in New York so who gives a [ __ ]
right with that my predictions for the
week
Pittsburgh Ravens I have no [ __ ] idea
uh Patriots Jets I have no [ __ ] idea
just for the simple fact I have no idea
which defense the Patriots are gonna
show up with you know I am NOT a guy if
you realize that I'm not a guy who buys
into hype that's why I have not bought
into Rex Ryan for half a [ __ ] second
and that's why also when the Patriots
won 45 to 3 I didn't go well there you
go
because I realize we also lost 28 to 14
I also know that we suck against the run
so I think if we're gonna win I'll tell
you from the Patriots I gotta be
thinking I gotta stop L T now seriously
if we can stop the run and go up by a
good 10 14 [ __ ] points and put
Sanchez into a situation where he feels
like he has to make a play we're gonna
be in it we're gonna be we're gonna be
all right that's what we need to do
that's what we need to do and I have
faith that we're gonna [ __ ] do that I
hope for the love of [ __ ] God because
if we don't you're gonna listen to the
sounds of a blubbering jackass next week
on this [ __ ] podcast and that is it
so that's it I'm really hoping oh look
at this look at this I got some offers
coming in I got some offers coming in
here we go where where am I going to be
performing oh by the way I'm actually in
the process of getting a Detroit and
Milwaukee date now I have not played in
Detroit since I did the rich [ __ ] tour
way back in the day with Charlie Murphy
and ashy Larry and I have not played
Milwaukee ever I know I did a college in
that area because a long time ago I went
to a Bucs game but what else do I got
going on of course I don't get the
[ __ ] internet here in my bedroom what
the hell is wrong with me
I'm stepping up my life in 2011 people
all right let's go with YouTube videos
for the week all right
oh here's something I've been watching a
lot of basketball lately and Kareem
abdul-jabbar always gets credit for
invent
the skyhook and I always took that as
law and I was just like yeah the guy
invented the skyhook Wow people must
have been like what the [ __ ] you know
they went from the set shot to that you
know the way they traditionally shoot
now at the one hand the other hand
guiding the ball and then he comes out
with that [ __ ] people must have just
been like where the [ __ ] did that come
from and then I was looking at some old
Celtics video and that was sort of a
shot that people already took in the 60s
but they did it from their hip and it
was one of the gayest looking shots
you're ever gonna see you just sort of
jumped in the air had one leg up in the
air bent at the knee like I don't think
that there's a physical way to do that
shot without going we as you through it
but uh he just saw that he changed it
where he didn't shoot it from the hip he
just put it over his [ __ ] head so
there you go um here's a nice conspiracy
theory one from people in I believe in
Seattle you go to a Seahawks game they
have a large beer and a small beer and
the large beers like a dollar
seventy-five more they come in two
different glasses so somebody filled up
a small glass with water and poured it
into the large glass and it filled it
all the way up it was classic the small
glass is a little fat one and the other
one's nice and tall so you think you're
getting more and you're not and they
charge you next to dollar twenty five
and somebody made a video of it um what
else what other videos do I have here oh
this is one from a new website totally
crap totally crap calm they got a lot of
good good videos and there's one there
called five minute fight all of these by
the way will be up on the mmm podcast
calm and what else oh this one is a
video also on totally crap calm and it's
also an underrated and it says
underrated ass-whooping so many things
would be solved if people would start
the kids out right and the name of this
video is old school ass whuppin and I
don't know how to describe this other
than this father puts on a video camera
he makes his kid tell him he's not going
to be in a gang and he starts beating
with the belt and the kid
tells his dad he's not that gangster
[ __ ] he goes don't tell me tell it
to the [ __ ] camera and he continues
to beat his ass with a belt it's uh sad
it's funny it's everything you want it
to be and then there's another video
that I saw right after that's five
minute fight and this fight is [ __ ]
hilarious there's two white kids they're
calling each other [ __ ] and they're
calling each other the n-word and I
swear to god they might both throw seven
hundred punches and I think they missed
six hundred ninety eight each it's the
classic thing we got two people who want
to fight they don't know how to fight
and all they know is they want to punch
the person other person in the face but
they don't want to get hit in the face
so they won't commit to coming inside
and they just sort of punching the
atmosphere around the other guy's head
or as I like to say an NBA basketball
fight you ever watch Oh NBA basketball
players fight for the most part they
pull their head behind their shoulders
and then they they throw punches like
they're trying to throw a [ __ ]
baseball from the outfield to home plate
alright I'm just really just giving
information this week I don't feel like
I'm [ __ ] oh here we go
no that's from last week Oh for Christ's
sake you cook this yeah the hell am i
here where the [ __ ] is my underrated
overrated for the week Oh
overrated underrated here we go
overrated NFL celebrations seriously how
many times do we have to see these
unoriginal athletes do the jump and the
chest bump after a touchdown his bunt
it's been done so much it's become
lackluster and automatic remember the
throat slash they would all do before
the NFL banned it for being too violent
a gesture I remember even Brett Favre
doing that one and still managing to
come off to white when he did it or what
about the fact that the celebrations
aren't even regulated to touchdowns
anymore
every sack tackle first down and catch
warrants a dance and a hey look at me
moment for the player this is the NFL I
expect Defence's to wrap a guy up and
make a tackle
I expect the receivers to catch the ball
they need to show some class and act
like they've done it before
not to mention
yeah I'm totally with you on that that
hole every time you catch a pass and
then you get up and you got it you know
the Jerome Bettis was that was the guy
always stands out in my head where he
would he would [ __ ] you know his
first 10 carries he get like 12 yards
and then he ripped one off for like 11
and then he get up and starts stomping
around taking off his [ __ ] chinstrap
I can't stand that [ __ ]
Braylon Edwards does that [ __ ] you know
drops like nine passes and then catches
one for a first down gets up [ __ ]
it's the worst thing ever
the Keyshawn the Keyshawn Johnson will
you stomp around and you take off you
[ __ ] chinstrap it's like well III I
hate that [ __ ]
I hate it I can't say I don't mind
actually if you catch a touchdown you do
a little [ __ ] dance actually I've
always liked that [ __ ] but like the the
first you know what's even worse is when
your team is kicking the [ __ ] out of
another team and then the other team
makes a good defensive play and then
that guy gets up I'm screaming at the
people in the endzone it's like dude
you're down 28 to 6 all right why don't
you go back to the defensive huddle and
figure out why the [ __ ] you weren't
doing that for the first three and a
half quarters you know so I go with you
I'm uh yeah I'm over all of that [ __ ]
and I think the worst thing I saw this
year was the tio Joe show well you had a
team that was absolutely [ __ ] the
bed yet their two best players had the
time to do a reality show
during the [ __ ] during the season do
you think Bill Belichick would put up
with that do you think that those guys
would not be shipped out for third-round
draft picks it's un-fuckin'-believable
the level of disrespect that that is to
do that [ __ ] show during the goddamn
season as you proceeded to leave lose
[ __ ] eight games in a row oh and then
you go on the show and you throw your
coaches under the bus there you go
and for those of you who wonder why
Randy Moss was traded for a third-round
draft pick that's why because of that
type of [ __ ] because it's really it's
just not worth it like you ever see a
beautiful girl in a bar okay or whatever
you start dating a beautiful girl and no
matter how hot she is she's just such a
[ __ ] it's not [ __ ] worth it
she's just so [ __ ] high-maintenance
that's what all those players are like
and all that all that all those types of
sports it's at the end of the day no
matter how [ __ ] good they are they
just not worth it they just not worth it
kind of like listening to the rest of
this podcast it's really not worth it I
feel like I haven't had anything to say
for the last [ __ ] 12 minutes alright
underrated bat baseball's code although
it's definitely borderline juvenile
sometimes I do like that in baseball if
you show up a pitcher by celebrating
your home run a little bit too much you
can guarantee he's throwing at you the
next time you're up
I like that players get to police
themselves a little bit well sir
why don't you come over to the NHL you'd
love NHL hockey you just basically
described why there's fighting in hockey
and why that's why hockey's awesome
and you know because they let the
players police each other
and I know people who don't like the NHL
they're gonna be like bye fighting yes
by fighting it has to be done
okay you got a guy skating around the
ice it [ __ ] 20 miles an hour with the
goddamn club in his hand okay if you
don't slap the [ __ ] out of him every
couple of games he's gonna hurt somebody
severely you know so that's that's
that's what needs to be done you know
think of all the piece-of-shit players
that are cheap [ __ ] in the NBA alright
in the NFL and all that just imagine if
they actually had a club in their hand
and they could walk up to your best
player and just [ __ ] slam them over
the head right in the [ __ ] grill or
in the side of his [ __ ] leg you know
you'd have to beat the [ __ ] though you
have to be a
loud to beat the [ __ ] out of that guy so
it wouldn't happen and I know what you
guys would thinking well if anybody does
that just ban him for life out of the
league
well then you would end up with nobody
playing hockey because I don't know what
it is if you've ever played hockey
there's something about it it's just a
very physical game and at some point
you're gonna think about it
well that [ __ ] get you for like
the fifth goddamn time you just that's
you got this club in your hand and you
just ceased I'm gonna [ __ ] come over
there I'm just gonna [ __ ] take
two-hander right to his [ __ ] neck but
you don't because their biggest player
will come over there and beat the living
[ __ ] out of you in front of your [ __ ]
girlfriend a wife who's in the stands
say did that make sense speaking of
which I'm actually playing hockey
tonight and yes I do suck I am a pond
hockey player I can only go frontwards
and cross over on one side bouquet I got
the helmet with the full cage you know
that's that's usually a sign that
someone's gonna be a cheap piece of [ __ ]
anybody who has all the extra padding
that's because they know somebody's
gonna come up and try to retaliate so
they want to make sure that they're
they're extra protective I actually wear
it because I know that my if I was ever
gonna make it to the NHL it would have
happened by now I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say that as a 42 year old I
don't think I'm gonna make it so there's
really no point in me getting the
required 18 stitches that starts above
my upper lip goes through my lips and
comes down I remember the Gary galley
one that was the most insane [ __ ]
scar I've ever seen Gary galley former
Bruin he's playing for the Boston when
he went to the kinks right he's playing
for the Bruins he's in front of the net
somebody gets cross-checked in their
chest the guy like he gets hit so hard
that both his legs fly up into the air
he's like in the air in the seated
position he basically kicks Gary galley
in the face with his skate just sort of
like as his legs are going up the blade
of the guys skate
catches Gary galleys [ __ ] chin goes
right through both his lips and right up
the side of his face and he had stitches
from I think the side of his nose right
down and right through both lips it
insta was one of the worst ones I ever
saw and you know and I think that's good
to conclude one of the worst podcasts
I've ever [ __ ] done
I felt like Sanchez during this whole
podcast at no point that I feel
comfortable I don't feel like I settled
down I feel like all my jokes went 10
feet over everybody's [ __ ] head and
if I could have handed this mic off to
somebody for the second half of it you
know and let somebody kick the last joke
through the uprights I would have laughs
I got to redeem myself did anything
funny happen to me this week I went out
I looked at some houses I think I'm
getting ready to go right back on the
wheel again you know after talking about
happen no goddamn dead I'm thinking
about just going out and buying a house
maybe buying a [ __ ] car I want to buy
something you know I want to fill the
void like only an American can somebody
sent me an email talking about how
America is over you know talking about
how China is now down there now they're
gonna be the [ __ ]
and you know what I say well it's about
[ __ ] time you know China how many
goddamn [ __ ] people do you have to
make before he can take over some [ __ ]
China that's the most overrated goddamn
[ __ ] country out there you know they
got like a third of the world's
population how the [ __ ] are you not the
best you should have the best guitar
players the best singers the best actors
the best scientists just out of sheer
[ __ ] numbers what do you guys been
doing over there I've been slacking off
slacking off with your [ __ ] awful
food and your dirty goddamn restaurants
do you know I won't eat Chinese food
because of that I'm not saying Chinese
people are bad food a bad people bad
food bad people I was like that was like
a Jeffrey Dahmer comment
I'm not saying Chinese people are bad
food I'm not saying that they're that
they're bad people
I'm not saying then that's
I'm just saying I lived in New York City
and I to be a fan of Chinese food I am
NOT a fan anymore
all right and until they start getting
some clean goddamn restaurants out there
I'm not [ __ ] eating at him that's it
I'm not saying you're bad people I'm
just saying what the [ __ ]
filthy
I'll only Allah lead Chinese food who's
gonna know if I'm shit-faced I'll eat
anything I don't give a [ __ ] but if I'm
sober the only way I'll eat Chinese food
is if it's a cloth napkin sit down nice
[ __ ] place all right
and to be fair that's why I don't eat
barbecue I'm not going into those
goddamn shacks with those [ __ ] flies
the size of goddamn bumblebees I'm not
going in there and I get it that's the
hole he's putting poor people food yeah
it looks like it it looks like it it
looks like you've been dominated on some
[ __ ] level Oh at the dirty floors and
the peanut shells [ __ ] barbecue and [ __ ]
Chinese food all right
I actually had some Lebanese food
yesterday which is just sort of all like
middle-eastern food like that that uh
chicken kebabs and all that stuff was
[ __ ] insane tabbouleh salad all right
I sign off on that I sign off on Indian
food I sign off on these are all the
ones I'll give you the that I like I
like Japanese I'll go with Korean
barbecue I'll go with that
Thai food I like that [ __ ] Chinese well
I think Chinese was the only one I won't
[ __ ] with you know and I'm Mexican food
Mexican food has to be a certain cut or
I'm not [ __ ] with it you know when
you go to the so some of those some of
those little [ __ ] shacks there and they
got the refi refried beans and it just
looks like you know it's like does the
Health Department even know this place
exists okay this is like a restaurant
slash it's like you turned the garage a
house into a [ __ ] burrito Factory I'm
not eating here
micro Alexa gives me [ __ ] because I'll
never get Chinese food you know and she
thinks that there's something like
borderline racist that I won't eat
Chinese food it's like I have no problem
with those people you know that's like
over it like overly think it's something
what I'm saying is is I want a clean
goddamn restaurant is that so ruined all
right that's the podcast for this
[ __ ] week I don't know am I am I
wrong about that [ __ ] I just said when I
think Chinese food I think dirty
restaurant that's that's what the [ __ ] I
think because that has been my
experience
so go ahead we're gonna take the next
caller after this break
hey what would you guys do if I started
doing commercials on my podcast as a way
to make money it's right in the middle
of calling somebody a [ __ ] I just did
something for like True Value Hardware
do they still exist or were they bought
out bought out by Best Buy do they still
exist all right anyways oh you know what
I actually forgot tonight that I can't
say this [ __ ] because I'm now [ __ ] it
I'm gonna say it I'm actually gonna go
see one of my favorite drummers of all
time tonight and Jojo Mayer is doing a
drum clinic and I'm gonna go check that
[ __ ] out and if you want to see this guy
drummers out there you got a [ __ ]
check this guy out this is gonna I'm
gonna have this up on the mmm podcast
com it's Jojo Mayer performing I plays
like that drum in drum and bass music
and it's him performing at the I believe
2005 Modern Drummer Festival it's just a
three-minute clip he could do like a
roll with one hand he's got that
push-pull Moeller thing I don't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing but uh this guy
is the [ __ ] and I'm actually starting to
like I can't get into drum and bass but
I'm downloading some of his [ __ ] just
because it's played by human beings and
I'm actually fascinated with drum and
bass because it melds both the
capabilities of Technology and then the
abilities of human beings to adapt to
the technology and raise their level of
performance you know remember that time
when I
told you guys about that that whole uh
uh of drum and bass music that whole
video that basic explained it was like a
[ __ ] drum break from a b-side of a 45
and then deejays took that drum loop
isolated every sound and then switched
it all up and created a whole bunch of
different beats and then sped it up to
the point that no human being could play
it until a guy like Jojo Mayer sat down
and figured out how to [ __ ] do it
it's it's incredible it's absolutely
incredible I'm gonna watch that guy
tonight I'm gonna get my ass kicked out
on the ice tonight playing hockey and
that's it I'm gonna be in New York and
we doing spots around the city before I
go down to Atlantic City so I make sure
that I am in shape for my my big gig
down there with Jim Norton Jim Breuer
and Dave Attell and I will probably
popping in at Gotham comedy club I will
be popping in at the Comedy Cellar
and stand-up New York and cut the comic
strip and Dangerfield's I'm gonna be
doing the whole [ __ ] loop like I used
to back in the old days back in the old
days which but I guess they don't do
that anymore now they book the club's a
month out and they just want you to work
at the at the same club the whole week
but back in the day
you still used to work like three four
clubs if you could on a weekend and you
do you'd have a nine o'clock here a 9:45
at another club at 10:20 here and 11:30
here all the way to like two o'clock in
the morning and you get $50 a spot and
you'd blow like a third of it on cabs
just driving all around the city and
you'd have a new idea for a bit and in
one night you could hash it out just
doing like you know sometimes up I think
the most I ever did I do like eight sets
in a night it was [ __ ] unbelievable
and it just caused you to write because
you didn't want to say the same thing
eight times in one night and you could
you could flesh out a bit I mean that
was basically like doing you know almost
headline weekend's you only do six shows
you would get eight shows on average six
so it was like doing an entire
we Kenworth the shows in one night
as far as running that same new bit and
it's incredible and I wish the New York
clubs would go back to doing that
because I really think that that was the
system that created all the great comics
that I watched when I came to New York
that's just my that's that's my two
cents and I'm [ __ ] sticking with that
that's it
do you guys watch 60 minutes by the way
that just reminded me of [ __ ] Andy
Rooney you guys been watching I we
watched that every week me India and we
just laugh our asses off at that
curmudgeonly old bastard and what the
[ __ ] is going on with his upper lip its
receded on both sides yet the middle
part still is fleshy so now it looks
like he has a pimple this upper lip all
right I got nothing people I'm talking
about [ __ ] Andy Rooney's upper lip
okay the podcast is over bill
Tapout it's over Oh congratulations to
Pete Carroll I was wrong about that
docker wearing white shoe Jerry Seinfeld
sneakers son-of-a-bitch they came out to
[ __ ] play worse defense performance
I've ever seen with the Saints and I
don't know I don't even know who the
[ __ ] they're playing next week I'm just
hoping that the my Patriots um praying
that we're gonna beat the Jets cuz I
have no [ __ ] idea which defense is
gonna show up but I'll tell you foam the
Patriots are gotta be thinking all right
that's the podcast for this week
everybody have a great week don't give
out your information of these [ __ ]
corporations for the love of God and if
you want to go ahead and do it stupid
alright go ahead and do it but then
don't be surprised when you know some
psycho you dated from high school is
standing on your front porch and has
your [ __ ] all your information all
right I couldn't even finish that
sentence who gives its [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll talk to you next week
[Music]
you